want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
these seven genius habits that will
improve your life
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one
track your expenses with david bach i
would teach this and i would tell people
you need to track your expenses for 30
days for 30 days go track your expenses
and like two people did it right so then
i was like okay you know what the seven
day challenge in fact i think we did
this we did this on oprah you know for
seven days track your latte factor oprah
when i did the one of the oprah shows
she we showed the latte factor and she
pulled off a cloth and showed this
woman's latte factory and we had a
quarter of a million dollars in cash
sitting on this table and we told people
for seven days track your expenses
a lot of people did that like tens of
thousands of people tracked their
expenses for seven days so i would love
it if people would go and take the
challenge and for seven days track where
their money's going everything you know
people are like well that include cash
yes does it include tim card yes checks
yes visa everywhere your money goes for
seven days track it and at the end of
seven days look at it and tell yourself
well what's in here that could be
changed
now i will say this some people can't
get through seven days really so really
so
a lot of times and i could do it right
now i say you know what just do it for
one freaking day
one day one day just take one day and
take a pad of paper and just write down
where your money goes for one day and
the only key here is don't change who
you are during that day don't go you
know don't change your behavior just
spend money like you always do and if
again if you're in a relationship have
your partner do this
and then look at it and be honest with
yourself you know i always think
benjamin franklin was famous for saying
a penny spent a penny saved is a penny
earned well today i'd say five bucks
saved is five bucks earned habit number
two have discipline with will smith when
you look at
um
the
athletes
right there's a certain extreme mindset
that
you
i was gonna say you have to take on i
don't know that you have to take it on
what i do know is that in this society
um
we worship that mindset
that um
you know it's the the can you become
michael jordan
without that mindset yeah
you know and
that is a that is a really
powerful difficult question it's like
most people can't sustain the mindset
yes
that you know fortunately because it's
it can be so destructive but most people
can't sustain
that level
of discipline to manifest the things
that they want
in in their life and
there's just a
there's a poisonous edge
to
that kind of discipline and i've been to
the edge of
that kind of material world discipline
in my mind and i can tell you you can
have a whole lot of stuff and be
miserable out there
on that edge and i found a much more
comfortable
uh
and productive space in my life and you
still need that discipline yes but it it
it's like when you're when you use that
kind of power to achieve things
it's like there's a uh
there's a there's a uh
brutal reckoning yeah
there's a brutal reckoning at the at the
end of that habit number three cheer for
yourself with mel robbins talk to me
about chasing your dreams and this quote
that you have that an aha moment does
not necessarily lead to an aha life
um
yeah the uber driver in dallas that's in
this book um i get choked up when i
think about him
uh an aha moment
i get choked up
because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day
you've got millions and millions of
people that
are inspired by empowered by impacted by
your content there are people out there
that
use your work as a lifeline
and it is humbling
and what i am
really present too
in the work that i'm putting out in the
stuff that i'm sharing whether it's my
failures or the things that i'm using
that are helping me and my own struggles
is just
how
much people are holding themselves back
and how
much pain people feel
because most folks know
what they dream about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against
what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
i hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going i got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
i don't know if i'm worth that i don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this i don't think i'm good enough
i've failed so many times i can't go
through that door
and that's the problem i want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life
that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
i'm the same way
and so this uber driver
the story that you're talking about i
get into the car
and
we start driving and i'm on the phone as
we're driving and i'm having a
conversation with somebody about this
daytime talk show that i launched which
was a dream with sony pictures
television and then uh was promptly
fired after season one it was a huge
failure because we didn't make it to
season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life
and so i'm talking to this person about
the talk show i hang up the phone and
this uber driver comes alive he's like
oh my gosh i can't believe you're in my
cab
and i'm like why and he says because i i
want to talk to you about something i
think you can help me and i'm like great
how can i help you and he says i have a
dream of being a oscar-winning uh actor
and creating opportunities for other
black and latino men to do the same in
acting and i'm like freaking fantastic
what the [ __ ] are you doing in dallas
right yeah the guy's 25 and so
i i go you know the game is in new york
and la i mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in dallas
but why are you not in la why are you
not in new york and he's like you're
right you're right you're right i need
to move to la like why not and he says i
have 700 in my bank account and i'm like
that's freaking fantastic you have 700
in a car
dude drop me off and get driving what
are you waiting for
and so we have this whole conversation
and i write about it in this book
where
i am actively arguing for his dream and
he is actively arguing against his dream
and
what is so sad
is throughout this conversation tom he's
like you're right 700 could get me there
you're right i am only 25. you're right
if i keep thinking and thinking and
thinking and thinking about what i want
to be doing i'm not only going to drive
in circles my whole life is going to
spin in circles as i think about what i
want and i don't do [ __ ] about it
and then you are going to find yourself
not at 25 but at 45 or 65 and you're
going to be so filled with regret that
you never put a put a bet on yourself
and so
this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
california and me giving him a bunch of
tools that i talk about in this book and
the point of the story is does he move
or not i don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us
we do not know how to do it for
ourselves
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there how about number four be an
infinite student with simon sonic how do
you create the environment where people
are going to thrive and create those
results that you're talking about what
does it you're asking me the question um
uh what does it mean to be healthy
you're asking me the question what does
it mean to be a great parent like i
don't have five things to be a great
parent right
it's a lifestyle and it comes number one
with the commitment that i am
responsible for the life of another
human being the growth of another human
being the closest thing to leadership is
parenting you have to be an infinite
student of parenting you know you want
to be a parent you ask your friends you
ask your own parents you join groups you
read magazines you watch talks whatever
it is you're constantly consuming how to
deal with this constantly changing
challenge of being a parent and it's ups
and downs and successes and failures you
know and that's what it is leadership is
the same
leaders great leaders are students of
leadership no matter how achieved they
may be
they're still learning
um and it's a lifestyle it's the
lifestyle of what i need to do to look
after people which includes things like
listening
uh learning how to give and receive
feedback
um learning how to have effective
confrontations how to discipline when
necessary in a way that's constructive
um
roam the halls get to know people
learning what it means to to ask
somebody questions how do you ask
questions
you know like some people are naturally
good at being curious about other human
beings and some people are uncomfortable
because they're introverts or whatever
socially awkward but we can learn
you know how do you learn to remember
people's names well i'm bad at names no
you've just decided you're bad at names
we can learn to be good at names so that
when we walk down the hall and say hey
tom
oh my god he remembers my name it's a
nice feeling it's a lifestyle
it's a lifestyle there are many many
things we have to do and constantly work
on to be a great leader to create that
environment habit number five step out
of complexity with jamie wheel the world
health organization
has now established
that more of us globally
take our own lives
then war
tornadoes
earthquakes
floods
famines and plagues combined
we have become our own
worst enemy
in fact the pressures of trying to
survive and thrive
in the world as we know it and live it
today
is so great
that a million of us
a year
opt to step off the mortal coil
rather than continue to try and face it
and fight it
and there have been many think pieces in
this last year in particular
about this notion of diseases of despair
right how particularly
for displaced middle americans
demographics typically 40 and up often
without college degrees
frequently wondering i mean here we are
at su
right talking about this bleeding edge
of future disruption they've been
disrupted
they don't see a world where they have a
part in it
and they're dying
of despair they're dying of these
diseases of despair as they are called
but maybe
maybe they're not diseases at all
maybe they're symptoms
symptoms of a larger
problem that we can't quite put our
fingers on
and what that problem might be
is that
we
our brains
and our minds and our bodies aren't
built for this
millions of years of evolution
right slow paced acute present embodied
very low bandwidth realities very high
consequence for not being present in
this exact moment
and now we're facing a world where
sin if you think from all of human
history until 2012
every bit of information ever created
the the libraries at alexandria
all right every song every story
every scripture and sacred text all of
it
from the dawn of time until 2012
we now generate that much data every 48
hours
so
we
are drowning
in information
and starving for motivation oh somebody
somebody gets a red flag where was that
little phone going off
goodness gracious
um
and what's happening is three things
volume what we just talked about
velocity how fast it's coming at us
right and complexity
because what's happened between the 20th
century and the 21st and i know you guys
are all deeply
vested in exactly this nut to crack
is that we've moved from complicated
problems how do you do kaizen in a
factory and get you know a million cars
off with good quality control and a good
price point how do you get the trains to
run on time you know thank you the swiss
right how do we solve for
lots of moving parts
but not that much ambiguity
right ultimately there's a there's
there's an app for that there's a manual
for that
but what we've done is we've stepped
across that chasm
and we've now entered the world of
complex problems and if you attempt to
continue to solve complex problems with
merely complicated process
you create wouldn't you know it more
complications how about number six
sleep with matthew walker what we've
discovered over the past um 10 or 15
years is that you need sleep after
learning to essentially hit the save
button on those new memories so that you
don't forget
so sleep will actually and future proof
that information within your brain
but recently we've discovered that you
not only need sleep after learning you
also need sleep before learning
and now to actually prepare your brain
almost like a dry sponge ready to
initially soak up new information
and without sleep the memory circuits of
the brain essentially become waterlogged
as it were and you can't absorb new
memories
let me show you um the data here so here
in this study we decided to test the
hypothesis that pulling the all-nighter
was a good idea
so we took a group of healthy adults and
we assigned them to one of two
experimental groups a sleep group and a
sleep deprivation group
now the sleep group they're going to get
a full eight hours of shut eye but the
deprivation group we're going to keep
them awake in the laboratory under full
supervision
there's no naps there's no caffeine by
the way it's miserable for everyone
involved and then the next day we're
going to place those participants inside
an mri scanner
and we're going to have them try and
learn a whole list of new facts as we're
taking snapshots of brain activity
and then we're going to test them
to see how effective that learning has
been
and that's what you're looking at here
on the vertical axis the efficiency of
learning so the higher up you are the
more that you learn
and when you put those two groups head
to head what you find is a quite
significant 40
deficit in the ability of the brain to
make new memories without sleep
i think this should be frightening
considering what we know is happening to
sleep in our education populations right
now
um just to frame that in context it
would be the difference between acing an
exam and failing it miserably 40 percent
and we've gone on to discover what
actually goes wrong within the brain to
produce these types of learning
disabilities
and there's a structure that sits on the
left and the right side of your brain
called the hippocampus
and you could think of the hippocampus
like the informational inbox of your
brain in that it's very good at
receiving new memory files and then
holding onto them
and when we looked at this structure in
those people who'd had a full night of
sleep we saw lots of healthy learning
related activity
yet in those people who were sleep
deprived we actually couldn't find any
significant signal whatsoever
so it was almost as though sleep
deprivation had shut down the memory
inbox and any new incoming files they
were just being bounced
you couldn't effectively commit new
experiences to memory and habit number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips
is live in a state of meditation with
guru paul das what does someone like you
do to meditate how do you meditate
when i came to the monastery the
meditation i was taught was mantra
meditation which is chanting on beads so
i chanted mantra
and as i began the process i realized
how
challenging it was
to be present
into the sound of the mantra
and to be totally
in a space in a zone of thoughtlessness
where there's nothing bothering your
mind and you're completely present
and listening to the sound and totally
absorbed
you know in the sound i realized that it
was a massive uphill
task and i think it comes that the
challenge comes from the fact that we've
got so used to multitasking
that our mind functions on 20 tracks
so when we're just on the meditation
track there are 19 other tracks to deal
with yeah you know you have your
personal life your relationship issues
you have professional issues there's so
many things going on if issues coming
from family
so much going on in the country so much
that's occupying our mental space when
you actually want to get onto the track
of meditation by kind of just putting
all of this in the back seat
it becomes practically
impossible and a lot of people tell me
this when they're trying to meditate
this is what happens to them and i share
my journey with them this is exactly
what happened to me when i started
it's been 25 years now every single day
without one day's gap one and a half
half hours every day
and i
and i tell them that it's not that it's
not a challenge today
it would be very high-headed to say that
okay i've reached the state of
enlightenment when i said for meditation
everything's kind of there and i'm
totally absorbed very high did i feel to
say that
but i did a few things that i feel can
benefit those who want to
really get into that a deeper state of
meditation
i
i look at meditation in two ways a is
the meditation meditation as in the
practice
and b is everything that we do in our
life as meditation
you know
and i prefer to work more on everything
in my life as a meditation which feeds
into my practice of meditation but you
do not neglect the practice and not
neglect the practice for sure
so uh
i'll tell you what i do for instance uh
one meal a day
i just eat by myself
two meals i take with my friends my some
of my monk friends where we discuss chat
eat
one male is just by myself
the reason being
i want to be present mindful
in the moment to savor the entire
experience of touching feeling
smelling tasting that food i avoid forks
and spoons as much as possible because i
want to touch and feel that experience
of the food now the reason i do it is
because it just means no phones no books
nobody to talk to and just being there
eating
correct
so what i'm doing is by just eating that
one meal by myself
training my mind
to be in the present
like we are talking now there's three
meetings lined up for me tonight and
there's a restaurant called candy and
greens that breech candy the family is a
very close friend you know so they've
just opened up a new rooftop terrace and
getting message after message could you
come down today evening for dinner right
but it's not in my mind
it's not on my mind nothing outside of a
conversation between you and me right
now is on my mind
so why why do i do it it's because right
now i'm training my mind to be in the
present when i used to be in the
bathroom i would sing like a big thing
for me used
because earlier i would sing a lot of
cinema and movie songs and now i sing
some spiritual songs bhajans whatever
and then one day i realized hey wait a
minute
this is not right
because neither am i into the singing
nor am i into the experience of bathing
so if i'm singing i'm missing the
experience of bathing and if i'm bathing
i'm not into my singing so why am i
doing two things at the same time
i stopped singing
just focusing on the experience of the
water
coming down my body and
experiencing that so to me these little
things
through the day
matter a lot to me and i think that's a
that's more of meditation to me because
then what i do here feeds into my
mainstream practice of meditation
and what i do here feeds into the little
things as well so it's kind of a loop
one feeding into other
the language you use
about yourself when you're by yourself
is what will make or break
your self-esteem
when we talk to other people when we
post on instagram when we share our
lives we always wanted to to look good
and be amazing and be so positive right
most people's instagram stories are are
just all of these amazing highlights and
how beautiful my perfect life is and
then you go home when you're by yourself
and you look at yourself in the mirror
and people you know cry themselves
asleep
what's the message when you talk to
yourself
what's the message when you're alone
what are you saying about yourself when
you can start to fix that self-talk that
inner dialogue that starts to shift
everything inside you to then create
amazing things outside you
[Music]
i remember when i first got started
making youtube videos my cell talk
was uh
in conflict because i had
my parents who i remember the voice you
know there's a picture of my parents
behind me on my wall in my office and
when people ask me what's my favorite
quote of all time it's it's what my
parents used to tell me that i'm evan
castrillo carmichael i could do anything
that i believe that i can
and that is a constant reminder that i
still
today you know at 41 still use still
tell myself still remind myself of like
i am having australia carmichael i can
do anything that i believe that i can
and it's helpful and valuable and what a
gift um so grateful for my parents for
that when i was getting started on
youtube though the other voice that was
in my head was
you're introverted you're shy
you suck on camera
um anybody who makes videos has a big
ego just needs to be famous
and so i really struggled with that
because i had competing voices in my
head
it wasn't even what other people were
telling me to do it was me myself when
i'm by myself thinking about myself
that constant inner struggle with the
voices in my head
left me
struggling left me making super slow
progress left me started and stop it and
started to stop and if you look at my
videos i started and then i took big
breaks and then i started again then i
took more big breaks and it wasn't until
i solved that inner conflict that i
started to get more results and i
started to be more
uh
productive and i started to
stop
stopping i started to stop stopping i
stopped procrastinating i just did it
because i wasn't so caught up in my head
and the discussion in the in the
dialogue and the voices and i just
replaced it with
better thinking about myself better
messages to myself
i think when you can do that your life
starts to change
because it's not other people's opinions
that we that really shape us it's
other people's opinions that then
influence our own self-talk then that's
what shape us the world that we're all
living in is our own construction and i
think that's the thing that people are
missing we have literally created this
world and if this world is delusion if
this world is destruction if this world
is filled with more bad than it is good
then that is a process of our thinking
that is a revelation
of how our minds work it is a revelation
of what we have built internally
so as leo tolstoy said everyone thinks
of changing the world but no one thinks
of changing themselves if we're actually
going to make change in the world if
those things you have in your mind the
vision of what you want to bring to the
world all of the ills that you want to
correct if you're actually going to
correct them
you have to look inward and begin asking
how is this your responsibility what are
the things in your thinking
that have helped manifest this world
that have manifested the problems in
your own life and that will my friends i
promise you
manifest the solutions
and as stephen hawking pointed out
the greatest enemy of knowledge is not
ignorance
it's the illusion of knowledge
we think we know something that we don't
we think we have the answers we think
within us already right now or the
fundamental building blocks that we're
going to need in order to build
something new but the truth is
the only thing that we already have is
the willingness to look
the willingness to change to leverage
the things that we have but we have to
build something entirely new we have to
understand that we don't yet know enough
that we are not adequate that we have to
look at ourselves and be willing to
stare nakedly at our inadequacies and to
adjust them to fix them to not hide
behind ego to not pretend or worse
believe
that we're already who we need to be
because the only promise i can make you
is you're not yet the person you need to
be to execute to create the change that
you want to make
but i can also promise you
that you can become that that if you're
willing to do the hard work of looking
internally and building something new if
you're willing to tear yourself down if
you're willing to brick by brick
disassemble that thing that has been
built by accident inside of you and move
forward with a new level of intention
and build something an entirely new
structure with your eyes open with
embracing and accepting
a lack of knowledge but never ignorance
of not
holding on to old ideas but to ask of
everything that you choose to believe
does this move me towards my goals or
not and if it does then you do it if it
does you believe it even more but if it
doesn't right then right there you drop
it
then you make room for the new
then you can build what you want to
build
then
we'll have the change that we want you
know i was in thailand and i saw the
golden buddha
and the story behind the golden buddha
is they had you know the the thai people
had this priceless object
and invaders were going to come into
thailand so they got the idea to put
layers of mud over the golden buddha and
you know the invaders didn't find it
and
you know many many centuries later
someone noticed this great monument of
mud
but there was gold
you know sparkling out of it and so they
went through the layers of mud and they
found the golden buddha
and i the metaphor for all your amazing
listeners and viewers
is simply this when we were born we were
born into possibility ah and wonder but
through our parents well-meaning
and the media
and our teachers our society and our
peers and the social media what happens
is
we adopt the psychology of average
versus the mentality of possibility and
legendary
and as we continue to leave the
perfection of childhood
we get hurt we get disappointed we don't
get invited to a birthday party we lose
a love we get stepped on we say i want
to be an astronaut and i want to be a
i want to be a billionaire and i want to
also be a great chef and i want to be a
yoga teacher and our teacher or our
friend says haha you're a fool here's
what the
day quit rule is and it's hard for me i
hate this one
i look at all my big project ideas you
know i don't know about you but i have a
journal with all my big ideas in it you
know or i have my vision board or i have
an excel spreadsheet of all these
different ideas and projects i want to
do and i've got like you know right as
an example right now i know my next six
books i'm going to write
i know
i know my next three campaigns i'm going
to launch
i know him
but here's what i have to force myself
to do and i don't like it
i say okay if this is a major project
that i want to do
even if it could lead to significant
growth
if i'm not going to start it listen to
this if i'm not going to start it in the
next 45 days
it's off my plate until next year
and
i push it to 2019. i literally just take
it from my journal
in my little bucket of things i want to
do this year and i put it out into 2019
and i feel
so
mentally relieved
a lot of people have a lot of anxiety
about the number of projects they have
on their plate that they really want to
do
and so what ends up happening is that
anxiety leads to a lot of
procrastination
that anxiety leads to a lot of poor
prioritization because there's so much
to do they're like oh my god there's so
much to do here so i won't do any of it
ever had that have you ever found
yourself in front of netflix going oh my
god i have so much to do but i just
watched the fourth video in the third
season has that ever happened you have
so much to and that's the problem you
have so much to do that you haven't
prioritized what you are going to do so
you don't do anything
so what i do is this time of year i look
at all those things that are on my plate
and i get honest
which ones am i going to start in the
next 45 days
and if i'm not going to start the next
45 day
put it in 2019. now it's not even on my
mental concern it's not on my dashboard
no anxiety there no oh my god i still
got to get that one in nope it's gone
that's the 45 day quit rule
i encourage you to challenge yourself to
try it patterns that have been
reinforced for 20 30 40 50 years
they're strong patterns
they're really strong patterns
so you don't change a 20 or 30 year old
pattern
in 20 days
by doing it 20 times or 30 times or 50
times when the other pattern has been
recreated and reinforced thousands and
thousands of times you operate your
whole day your whole week your whole
month your whole year based on the
patterns that have been there put there
and reinforced yes so what if i set you
train your brain for 100 days
and replace the old disempowering or
negative or destructive patterns with a
new pattern but deliberately yes
deliberate it's called deliberate
conscious evolution i'm deliberately
going to choose to change myself
and if you committed to that think about
what what would happen if we said let's
say you're out of shape and we said you
know what um let's go for a one minute
walk every day
not an hour one minute yep
so the first you know week we go wow
this is easy one minute walk i can just
walk around my house for a minute here's
my guarantee will happen at the end of
one week so let's do a minute and a half
and let's do two minutes and then let's
do three minutes and then at 100 days
you might be at let's say you're at an
hour a hundred days later because you
actually enjoy it
what do you think would happen to your
beliefs to your confidence your physique
to everything if you were to exercise
gently lightly for one hour a day change
your life completely transform so let's
start with self-talk let's start with
eliminating our self-deprecating you
know discussions with ourselves and if
we want to change our limiting beliefs
why not start with asking what
empowering beliefs do i want to have
and then what are ways that i could
actually create that pattern in my brain
so reading an affirmation
and closing your eyes and actually
feeling what that's like if it was true
and how would you behave if that was
true and what kind of comments would you
get if that was true
activates
not only the left prefrontal cortex of
your brain the occipital lobe part of
your brain the emotional part of your
brain and the motor cortex of your brain
but that is what it requires to rewire
the brain with a new more empowering
pattern most of us are asking for things
that aren't even clearly linked to what
we are actually missing
and so i'll give an example of this i
have so many clients that i coach or so
many people that i work with where the
number one thing they want from their
partner is time
and like i wish my partner had more time
brendan i i wish they just gave me more
time now the amazing thing is me and
brendan are giving each other time right
now but what if i was like this the
whole time right what if brendan was
writing another best-selling book at
this time
and and we kind of talked but imagine we
did that the whole time it looks like
you're present there with them
but
you're not when this is like this is
like a force field between you your
phone your
your task your thing i love that time
yeah that's so good this could be a book
this could be a newspaper this could be
email whatever it is but it's
interesting people say i want more time
and so people come back from a weekend
away
and then they'll go back to their pond
and be like i wish we spent more time
together and the other partners going
well we just went all going on a weekend
and they're thinking but no but you were
at the beach and i was with the kids and
it that wasn't so what are people really
asking for i've realized that over this
time people are asking for three things
when they're asking for time they're
asking for presents
they're asking for attention and they're
asking for intimacy i constantly believe
you got to feed your mind and and
challenge your body because the mind
body works together you know what stops
people as we said is fear well fear is
physical you feel your throat your gut
but if you do something really
physically strong on a regular basis you
develop a new emotional habit and that
emotional habit will get you to follow
through and do things differently that
people won't do it's really not that
complex there are a few habits in your
life that truly could change your whole
life i start every single day with this
process called priming training my brain
to be in a peak state because we get
primed all the time you know people
aren't aware of it but there's a study
that was done not long ago where they
took some people 100 actors they walked
up to 100 people in a park and they
rehearsed doing the same thing every
time they reach in their pocket to get
their phone and they or they hand the
person a cup of coffee and then they
reach in their pocket looking and say
would you hold this to me for a second
to a full stranger they grab their phone
look at it type it and they take it back
well thank you so much
the same for everybody but then they
come back 30 minutes later with somebody
with uh and the only difference by the
way is 50 of them have iced coffee
50 of them have hot coffee got it now a
person comes by 30 minutes later with a
clipboard gives him 20 and said if
you'll give me literally a minute and a
half of your time to read this three
paragraph story and answer these two
questions this is yours nine eight tens
of people take the 20 bucks and do it
they read the story same story for
everybody
but half the people when they ask them
the main character how would you
describe the qualities of the main
character the character traits the ones
that got iced coffee all say the person
was cold and uncaring 81 say that come
on hot coffee 80 or one percent
different say the person is warm and
genuine and the only difference is 30
minutes earlier somebody primed them see
you think it's your thoughts much of
your thoughts have been primed by the
environment by the media by what you
read to by your family by your friends
by your culture by your background so
what i do every day is i prime myself
for what i want rather than letting the
environment control me there's no such
thing as a mistake everything happens in
divine order i am being guided to learn
and grow here we go people
when we look at the situations in our
life from a place of regret
we ultimately miss the opportunity for
growth
we miss the opportunity to see what
could have been
beneath that discomfort we miss the
opportunity to acknowledge and recognize
that every experience in our life is not
an accident it doesn't happen by
accident it happens in a divine order
and when we live and lead and show up
for our life
grounded in that belief system
then we can face our most
difficult moments
with a
sense of purpose and power
and we can show up for those moments
with a opportunity to grow focusing on
the opportunity to grow focusing on the
opportunity for a shift for strength for
spiritual awakening for a new way of
being and a new perception of our lives
so that's a lot i know that's a lot i
know that when something really bad
happens like what we've been
experiencing recently in the world what
we experienced in the united states last
week when we experienced something like
a pandemic we don't want to see the
spiritual assignment we don't want to
see that this is not a mistake
but typically when difficult things
happen they are revealing what needs to
be healed these uncomfortable moments
whether they be global or they be
personal are revealing what we have to
heal whether we have to heal it on an
individual level which is where it
begins and what we have to heal on a
global perspective on a global level so
showing up to all these uncomfortable
moments and recognizing them that they
are not a mistake that they are
happening in a divine order and it's our
opportunity to perceive these situations
from the lens of what can i learn from
this how can i grow from this how can i
shift from this how can i lean towards
more love how can i lean towards more
joy how can i lean into the lesson
rather than the problem the solution
rather than seeking all of the faults
and and looking for all of the problems
look at a lot of people don't embrace
discomfort it's like
well it's not shocking it's like well
why the [ __ ] would you you've got two
meal 2.5 million years of evolution
telling you don't be uncomfortable
that's a dumb idea your brain is
screaming at you not too so there needs
to be this moment where you have this
realization and tipping point that like
oh always leaning into comfort is
causing a problem in my life
and i have to push back against that
because if you don't you're just gonna
keep slipping and we're seeing that with
what's happening in society right now i
mean
just take the epidemic of obesity i mean
that is the number one driver of health
of health problems of chronic disease
it's like
people today we might be living longer
than ever on average but are we actually
living like there's a difference between
lifespan and health span you know if if
you really want to live a full life
you're not going to look back at your
life and be like wow i'm i'm so glad
that i watched netflix and ate dominoes
every night like
you're gonna look back at your life at
the end of it and be like man i did some
pretty rad
i did spartan events i climbed mountains
i did x y and z like you need to
reinsert these sort of
uh metaphorical lions back in your life
if you really want to live fully and
be healthy as well i think that if we
share
the same experiences because we like the
same things
we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions i can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information
and if we share the same energy energy
is information so many people as an
example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so i
suffer more than you then you say i you
i suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
uh but goes to the same means if you if
you're if you're someone who's has a uh
accountability partner that that you
exchange ideas like this with and it's a
different frequency and different energy
so when energy comes together and it's
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and you feel
an elevation if there's dissonance
then your your sensing meter is how you
feel about that person many times in
your gut or in your heart or wherever
and there's decon there's a
destructive interference and there's no
energy involved so
i think that's just a practice but
really
the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such residence
such coherence
that when you walk in the room that you
raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition and that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model
that we use so imagine 1 500 people
in an event
where everybody's getting super coherent
and the interference that's going on in
the room is creating these high
amplitudes now we've measured that in
the room and the energy in the room is
off the chart many times there's i mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude freedom bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency
so but it turns out you can have a
collective group of people with a lot of
energy and be incoherent and it creates
entropy yeah you could have a smaller
group of people that are highly coherent
and put out a very big signal
so when we see a collective really get
coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that i would i would
never expect i mean i i don't i don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
i think our i think our our truth meter
is really whether we feel it lifted
uh or we feel like uh we've been robbed
let's say that you wanted to build a
better i'll give you i'll give you an
example breaking a good hat or building
a good habit and breaking a bad one so
one of the laws is to make it obvious
and this largely comes down to like what
we're exposed to each year each day and
minimalism and simplicity plays a big
role in this um in the book i call it
environment design that's basically the
strategy so for a long time i realized
that i brushed my teeth twice a day but
i didn't floss consistently and when i
looked at that habit one of the reasons
that i wasn't flossing consistently is
because the floss was hidden in the
drawer in the bathroom so i just
wouldn't see it you know like i wouldn't
open up the drawer and remember
so i bought a little bowl and got some
of the pre-made flossers and put them in
the bowl and place it right next to my
toothbrush so now i brush my teeth put
the toothbrush down pick the flosser up
it's right there just that one little
environment design change is pretty much
all i needed to do
to build the habit of flossing every day
on the other side let's say you know a
lot of people feel like they spend too
much time watching tv or playing video
games or just looking at a screen
but if you walk into pretty much any
living room where do all the couches and
chairs face they all face the television
so it's like what is that room designed
to get you to do it's designed to get
you to watch tv
so there are a variety of uh
levels to this you could for example
take the remote and take it off of the
coffee table and put it inside a drawer
or you could take the television and put
it inside like a wall unit or a cabinet
so you don't see it
you could also increase the friction of
the task so you could like take the
batteries out of the remote
after each use and then you know it's an
extra five or ten seconds put it in
maybe that's just enough time if you
think do i really want to watch
something or am i just doing this
mindlessly
you could
unplug the tv after each individual use
and then only plug it in if you can say
the name of the show you want to watch
so you can't like mindlessly browse on
netflix
and i mean if you really wanted to be
extreme about it you could take the tv
off the wall
put it in the closet and then only take
it out when you really wanted to watch
something but the point here and this is
kind of the principle of environment
design in general which is
you want to put fewer steps between you
and the good behaviors and more steps
between you and the bad ones letting go
of energy that's clouding your vision
and holding you back
it's a life practice that i learned long
ago that has freed me
so many ways it's a fact that holding
grudges against somebody who's done you
wrong
or
replaying revisiting hurtful situations
in your head over and over only weighs
you down and prevents you from being who
you're meant to be
right now because you're still
energetically holding on to the past the
energy that you put into constantly
rewinding to the resentment why did they
do that why did they say that to me i
didn't deserve to be treated that way
all of that only keeps you stuck
it will never change what happened
you've got a press stop and reject the
urge to keep replaying
so that you can then fast forward into
the now for yourself you know
a lot of people think
that holding on to things that
disempowered them is going to somehow
magically turn it around
as i said in my message a couple weeks
ago about forgiveness
you have to release the notion give up
the hope that the past could have been
any different and you also must release
the idea that people would do what you
might do in any given instance this is a
big one i had to learn and relearn
before i actually got it expecting
people to do what you would do in a
situation only leads to your
disappointment
not theirs they're going on with their
life
so let people be who they are and either
you accept it
or you don't
not doing that keeps you stuck in a
circumstance that actually costs you
time costs you energy and i can
guarantee that oftentimes the person on
the other side of the bitterness you're
holding on to they're not even thinking
about you
in fact they probably have just moved on
they certainly aren't obsessing the way
you are think of it like letting go of
any bad habit that just doesn't serve
your well-being not an easy task
taking the road to a more enlightened
healthy existence never is so
this is what i want to ask you to ask
yourself
why
am i holding on to this
how is this serving me
and really think about the
answer maybe it makes you feel validated
maybe it makes you feel righteous
or maybe
taking on the pain is your way of
recognizing the injustice so that even
though it won't be made right
it can at least not be forgotten
then i ask you
again ask yourself
do you want to be right
or do you want peace
this was huge for me
the unfortunate fact is that having both
may not be possible and also you may
never get your moment of righteousness
so why wait for it choose peace
what i know for sure
is that in this world
time is a moving on and it's our most
valuable commodity you can never get it
back
so staying in that loop playing it over
and over in your head of hurt only
amplifies your pain let it go
exhale make room in your heart for
something that is uplifting
surround yourself with people who want
the best for you you have the ability to
shift the dna of your spirit and control
how you perceive life so why not lighten
your load and let it go
jesus told his followers
all the miracles that i can do you can
do them but even better than i can and
you don't believe it and that was the
whole damn thing in a nutshell
if you don't believe it you can't do it
and i said well where's belief come from
mind i say and then what have you been
programmed you can't do and i say then
you'll never be able to do it
and this is the problem and and so we
talked about
way number one you want to change it
hypnosis because that's the original way
things went in in the first place and
you're you know you that what you said
was true
even just say i feel amazing i feel
amazing if you repeat that the mind will
will all of a sudden change how you feel
that's that's how it does it okay so i
say number one self-hypnosis number two
after age seven you still learn how to
do new things that become habits like
you didn't learn how to drive a car
until until later than seven but once
you know how to drive a car remember the
first day you got in it was like oh my
god looking out the windows checking the
mirror watching the gauges keeping your
feet on the pedals just correctly you
know looking paying all these attentions
like
and i say today you've been driving for
a while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am i going to do when i get to the
store
you're not even thinking about driving
why it's a habit okay i say well how'd
you get that habit because you're older
than seven how'd you get it i said
repetition that's what makes a habit
practice you want to play an instrument
i'll hand you an instrument yeah you
didn't have any practice then you're not
going to be able to play it and i say oh
practice what is that repetition
that's the second way of subconscious
learns
repeating something over and over and
over again because that's called
habituation making a habit and i love it
the new age today thing is fake it till
you make it like what the hell is that i
say you're not happy yeah most of us
have trouble being happy and i say but
what if every day all day long and you
can remember you say i am happy in spite
of the fact that what the hell is going
on you just say i am happy
i am happy
i am happy i go why what's going on i
say repetition
and there'll be a point where you're
repeated to the degree that the
subconscious which learns by repetition
will put in i am happy i said then
what's the consequences what's the
function of the mind take that program
and manifest it now that it's in there i
am happy i wake up one morning and guess
what i don't have to say i'm happy it's
automatic i'm already happy all day long
why my program said that 95
is coming from that habituation
you know repetition
of the exact thing you want not future
vision as if you have it now
we'll put it in a program so that's
first seven years hypnosis after seven
years uh repetition habituation is how
you change it
uh a sticky note people put that stuff
on a mirror or someplace and they go oh
yeah the little sticky note and i go
that is not repetition that's a
suggestion
a repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving the car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real
okay so the first two things are
uh hypnosis
second thing is repetition
and thirdly the most
you know
effective
uh is called energy psychology and i go
what's energy psychology
it's called super learning so what the
hell is super learning i go maybe you've
seen somebody read a book
by picking up a book and just moving
their finger down the page just like
that just as fast as that
and guess what
the subconscious mind the super computer
that it is has read every word just by
moving your finger down that has read
every word on that page and a person
using this super learning technique can
go into a bookstore open up a book in
five minutes later by thumbing through
each page turn the page turn the page
turn the page they can read a whole book
in five minutes that's super learning i
say if you can engage that function
you can also use super learning to
create
new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes
it's like
i go absolutely and it's so important
why because uh there's an old phrase
that's really critical it's called
necessity as the mother of invention
and i say what's happening we're facing
a mass extinction due to human behavior
that is compromising the web of life
humans are creating this through our
behavior our culture i say you want to
survive this epi this whole you know
extinction event
well then you have to create something
different
you have to change behavior starts with
you being completely honest with
yourself
on where you are right now in history
where are you after covet
where are you that the world has changed
where are you with your confidence where
are you with your income where are you
with your career
where are you with your happiness around
those things where are you with your
relationship
where are you with your health your
connection to a higher power
there's lots of things we can use this
tool for to get complete honestly get
completely honest because let's just say
it like it is
all change starts when you're brutally
honest that you're disturbed by standing
still you're disturbed by inaction
think about it that's how we move that's
how the rocket gets off the ground is
being disturbed with leaving your life
the way it is so unfortunately you're
like oh now i'm listening to this
podcast and i'm going to get disturbed
yes because if you're agitated you move
right
so let's pick your career your income
what you do for a living
where are you with that
are you happy with your career are you
happy with the business that you started
are you happy that
you started the business but it's not
really going where you want
listen we all make decisions for one of
two reasons we're either moving away
from something painful or we want to
move towards something pleasurable right
we either have to get out of this job or
we lost our job or it's just toxic or
it's not making me the money i have to
move or it's okay it's not bad but you
know you have another level you know god
designed way more for you than you're
doing
and the inaction of either one of those
should disturb you either away from the
pain or towards the pleasure so
at any time you could stop and write
this down or come back at another time
or type it in your phone if you were
being completely honest about your
income your career uh what you do for a
living starting the business or not any
of those
if you're completely honest where are
you because all change starts with a
starting point right all directions on
your gps you need the starting point
where are you as the starting point now
that the world has shifted sometimes you
know things like cove would pull back
the curtain and made us make us really
analyze our lives and we don't want to
go back to who we used to be i get it i
see it every day okay the next thing if
you know where you are now
then we have to decide where do you want
to go now
right now where do you want to go that
sounds like an obvious question i want
more success i want more happiness i
want more joy if it's not defined if
it's fuzzy fuzzy targets don't get hit
we need a definitive plan we need to
know exactly what our compelling future
is we need that lighthouse to drive
towards and what is that for you
most people know what they don't want
that's just a true story most people
know what they don't want they're
avoiding potholes they're driving away
from problems but they're not driving
towards where they want to go if you and
i jumped in an elevator together and i
said hey it's a year from now and it was
the best year of your life what's that
look like where do you want to go
would you be able to literally in four
or five sentences tell me where it is
you want and where you want to go or
would you go wow good question dean let
me think about it because that's what 90
of the people say i've been asking
people for over a decade
good question let me think about it
how do you know how can you get to where
you want to go if you don't have your
gps on where it is you want to be i set
a goal in 1973
i set a goal that i was going to build a
company and upgrade all over the world
i had
left the night galconic corporation
and decided that i was going to do this
because i didn't agree with the way they
were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
uh they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so i decided i would leave and start my
own company
and i wrote down i'd build a company and
operate it all over the world i got a
call last night from mikey about nine
o'clock something like that
and then she told me
that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of that
we had a broadcast going on here at 10
o'clock this morning
some of you'd be familiar with some of
you may have been on it
and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that move
meant this is really accurate today
we're only limited by weakness of
attention and poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised i don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
is called a terror barrier
the way i'm going to explain this to you
i come up with sitting in a restaurant i
remember it was at a holiday inn
restaurant
it was at dixie and uh just south of the
401 highway
in toronto a man asked me if i would
meet with him he had a problem
and
i was going to show him how he could
solve the problem
and he explained it so i took a pen and
some paper and what i'm going to show
you here is essentially what i showed
him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through
when you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
freedom this is something you taught me
is about really being unattached to the
outcome like being unattached
to whatever it looks like and knowing
that if i keep focusing on my heart if i
keep focusing on giving if i keep
focusing on growing if i keep posting
i'm loving people and loving myself
then i'm going to reject and attract the
right things in my life whether it be my
relationships intimately business
partnerships friends you're going to
repel
people that don't want to be in that
energy and you're going to be a magnet
to beautiful things
and that's why like the first time in my
life in my mind i'm like
my mind is calm and my heart is at peace
because i'm not attached to something
needing to look a certain way
it feels beautiful i went to iron man
iron man arizona and i was spectating
and i have no idea what his name is but
i watched the fourth place professional
he was either fourth or third come
across the line and this dude looked
like you i mean he was yoked and i was
like okay
you can look like an athlete and still
have success in this in this game
and so then i just real because my
passion is truly like
lifting and and and that that's where
that's where my i started and wrestling
and fighting and all that and so when i
saw that dude i was like okay
i might be able to be successful in this
sport and i just fell in love with the
the diversity of it and the training
and then what i learned was a lot of
this is mental
and going back to my roots was was
triath i mean what was was wrestling and
again if i win or i lose it's my fault
and i loved that and so i just started
to implement
um the mental side of stuff and the
nutrition side of stuff and it just
became this like big challenge for me
and over time it just escalated and i i
would try one thing and i gained
experience and and i um
totally long story but i we lost
everything in the economy i used to own
a mortgage company and and all of these
things happen and and i i remember doing
my first iron man triathlon
and
um i
i just fell in love with it it and it
was hard to have the perfect race and
again it was like i i can do better i
can do better i can do better and you
just keep going back to the drawing
board trying to do better and i started
working for a charity and it was a
charity in africa and we ended up
breaking the world record for the most
half ironmans done in a year
and and it was so cool because it was
the hardest thing i could think of it
totally pushed me physically and
mentally
and and as you know the number one
question that a lot of people get that a
lot of people ask or want to know in
today's day and age is like how do i
become more mentally tough it's like how
do and i'm like well
you have to show up a lot of people
don't read because they're afraid of
books
the books aren't their friend so you
might want to get a few books and kind
of make them your friend
you can start with
simpler books you know like fiction
there's lots of good fiction written for
adolescents and children
it's pretty straightforward you can
start there
if you're interested in philosophy
there's lots of
simple guides like the idiot's guide to
um
different topics or a beginner's guide i
read those things all the time when i'm
first investigating a new topic
you know i start with the introductory
material
um and i make time for reading like
and it was that was encouraged in my
family like i always read before i went
to sleep i read
and i i still do that
um
somewhat less so because i've become so
distracted by social media
but uh
you set aside a bit of time every day to
read and for me it was always just
before i went to bed i go to bed turn
the light and read for when i was a kid
for hours but
and if you do something every day you do
a lot of it and so i would say well if
you want to read if you want to make
yourself educated just put aside
20 minutes a day to read or 10
you know some small amount of time that
you could actually steal not two hours
because good luck man
it's very unlikely you'll manage that
but 20 minutes a day
you know that's
two hours a week that's 700 hours a year
you know that's
even if you're a slow reader that's a
good number of books
and so you make it a habitual part of
your life and you decide that it's going
to be something that you value you
investigate carefully what resistances
you might have to that idea because you
might think well that's
uh
pseudo-intellectual or
there's something more productive i
could be doing or i'm intimidated by
books or i hate books because i wasn't
good at reading when i was a kid and was
humiliated because of it or you know
you've got something against
intellectuals or
god there might all sorts of resistances
to picking up a book then you could
listen to audiobooks that's a good way
around that by hooker by crook man
so
you value it you make it a regular part
of your life you practice doing it and
and you you need a higher goal too it's
like well why should you read
well
it's so that you're more informed and
you can think better why should you be
more informed and think better because
you won't walk blindly into so many pits
you know you'll be able to negotiate
better in your life because you'll be
more
informed and more verbally fluent and
you'll have a better sense of how the
world works and be able to hold your own
in conversations and that'll make you
more confident those are all
unbelievably good reasons
to be highly literate is is an
incredibly
massive massive advantage
practical advantage you know and it
shouldn't be underestimated when
something happens with a partner or
friend and
even a co-worker or or a supervisor and
you're bringing up all the other times
that you've experienced that in the past
that's baggage
when you start your statements
about
why you do something a certain way or
what you're not going to do because of a
certain experience
that's baggage
and these are just common everyday
things this isn't even the hard stuff i
want to give you some unpacking skills
for just the common everyday normal
baggage that we walk around with these
human beings if one person tells you
you're a horse
you don't have to believe that
if two people tell you you're a horse
you you may want to listen
but by the time three people tell you
that you're a horse
you need to check yourself because i bet
you got hay hanging out your mouth and
your tail is wagging
in other words if you keep hearing the
same thing from different people at
different times about you you need to
unpack that baggage
and don't hear it as criticism or make
people wrong or bad ask them what they
mean i remember when my my grandson told
me that i was mean
and and i had heard that but i never
paid any attention to it because moi i
mean i'm a being said i can't be mean
but when i sat and i listened to him and
i realized wait a minute he's not the
only one saying that to me
i had to hear it and i had to unpack it
so when you hear one or two or three
unrelated people
telling you the same thing
don't dismiss them ask them tell me more
about that because there may be some
baggage that i have to unpack
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know the seven habits that will
make you one percent better daily check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there everybody's pointing
fingers instead of saying
we've had it really good for a bunch of
years
and the question is now what is our
competitor revealing about our own
weaknesses that we can